ready to take the Battle of Alberta outside for
the first time in the 20th anniversary of the
NHL's first outdoor game the flames and Oilers
in the Tim Horton Heritage Classic from soldout
Commonwealth Stadium what a great setting this
is what a great day it really is 20 years ago
it was so bitterly cold it almost felt like it
wasn't going to happen this time couldn't have
a better evening and just a great rivalry and
a game that means so much to both these teams
looks like you're going on offense b f with
the good active stick now you're scrambling
to come back but an excellent effort of T there's
Ryan nen Hopkins winning that little puck battle
getting it across the G be coac moving the puck
rebound scor kak moved in and an advon area kid
has the opening goal up the Tim Horton Heritage
Classic as D settle returns we on D settle got it
with Drive in the from scor D settled with so much
patience there you're counting down on the first
penalty newon Hopkins getting set to return here
comes a chance Mackenzie Winger TIY front and I
think cry has his first of the Season TR settle
again now mcdavis turns in the zone cross the B
most the dry settle Shar an answer from the
Oilers and it's 3-1 turnover just inside the
Zone a two-on-one down low and markstrom slides
across just a little hesitation as nen Hopkins
couldn't quite get control of it earlier these
couple of early saves there's just trying to slow
down McDavid but that pass through the scene
quick little one timer and you know speed you
you try to keep it to the outside as weager does
there but watch this play by dri side maybe just
a little guilty of one two many passes but behind
the back no look he he's one of those guys who
can make that save but again here's the one good
chance the cross team path but you saw it just a
little hot there AR getting set to return weaker
able to work his way through it's get scorers of
the rebound as you mentioned a little misc in the
middle of the ice those little flip passes could
create some habit and there's a great example of
it Ryan with the pass and hallway just unable to
gather control lost it as he tried to get it up
and over but how about this moment you know these
outdoor moments are really special really de har
thought that it was going to be anander K goal
instead it goes back to him his first career goal
in this kind of [Music] environment it's a center
c a two bab the length chance kep alive at the
line and now out empty net ofer Kane and that
one will go to 91 and it's 5 to Edon and the
four game windless streak for the Oilers has
ended this is U an amazing hos he's only come
uh you know you know once or twice in your
lifetime